[Music]
first responders have rescued thousands
of people in the houston area from the
dangerous flooding southwest of houston
our crews found a family who says help
never came even though they called 9-1-1
several times david begno joins us from
ireland david good morning
gail good morning i'll tell you about
that family in a moment but first just
caught up with truett allen they have
rescued a hundred people they did that
yesterday he's got a couple of buddies
with him where are you headed right now
we're headed over to a apartment complex
off of raised wood where there's 300
people trapped okay now this apartment
complex we had heard something about
yesterday so they've been stuck at least
since the early part of yesterday right
correct okay have you been able to get
in there prior to this
yesterday we were over on that part of
town but we didn't have enough time
there's there's a lot of rescue boats
over there all right okay we'll let you
roll good luck thank you uh the coast
guard helicopters are in the air by the
way now that it's daylight we see them
circling the bayou behind me that family
gail was mentioning here's how that went
down we were with a couple of good
samaritans like truett right there and a
guy walked up and said hey my fiance and
her family are stuck in the house can
you help me the guy said sure let's go
and so we hopped in the boat and this is
what we saw
this was my family i hope somebody would
come for them
floodwaters surrounded houston's
meyerland neighborhood it looked like
the rapids on sunday night as we rode a
motorboat toward a family in desperate
need
the water was about ankle deep it was
invading their home and the bands with
two dogs and the cat needed to get out
they had concerns about grandma
molvita's health that meant they needed
an evacuation plan and they needed it
fast lift one leg after waiting 18 hours
for help to arrive it took just a few
minutes for them to get themselves and
whatever essentials they could put into
a couple of bags and get out
christine band said despite multiple
calls to 911
the help never came
it would like ring busy or it would die
out or
and
eventually when we did get somebody they
said we didn't forget about you you're
on the list we're you know they're
coming nobody came for us in their case
it was love that saved the day
it was my fiance that called nikki band
says her fiance flagged down a couple of
volunteers he flagged down some civilian
rescuers yeah so
yeah that's really awesome because we
would have been stuck here for
days
on dry land there were kisses for him
and hugs of appreciation for jeff chase
and brian brees two volunteers who made
a texas-sized difference
two really good guys civilian samaritans
all you need is a good heart and a boat
you hear the sirens the crews are back
out again the coast guard is in the air
and the city of houston is still asking
margaret if you've got a boat and you've
got the time to help come on down
yeah david thank you and we heard that
from the coast guard
from the admiral there himself pitch in
texans help you can't you know it's
interesting they say the demand has
exceeded the resources but when you're
the person that needs help that's not
what you want to hear and as david said
the guy said let's go let's just go and
do it